ми супру ось же йому спи вробитники в
червоного Христа до купи яньска для
евакуації мирних жителів район одне знай
небо найпрекрасніших Помста рятують з лінію
фронту
постійно їздиш їздиш
Адреналін же ти по сину їздиш їздиш
скін вивертаєш
лицар діток щеб з барих ти людям життя
присипаєш червоні причому борошно рись Ну
праворуч людинного невтома ще буваєте
для
інститутах районі
обстріли
тут зі сорому послідовного
сьогодні салону уколи тимисто анна-то і
троє маленьких дітей полювання на вигляд
тут із роду
Анни
оленати на щастя Єсенін ви вирішили
Ага, тільки я покинув хату
моя двоє дітей
І куди я вийду я не буду
Олина написала на воротах люди цедіти
з подіають шість всі сторони хочеш
Якість За Христом я до ще росіяни
повернутися
Івану приблизно скільки трамвая
повномасштабний вторгнуне Росії до
України в нічний час на його життя
пологи на провела в підвалі хуявшись
відстрілили другий російських позовних
Анна йди ти завищують надспачну зону
Алла багату Хто наважується близько двох
тисяч Осип підписала відмову видів
евакуації та та ще війни у ​​повідомлю
родзинку свого рішення багатого Хто в
клуб яньскусу зустрічаючи нас у пиці
інчери сповідають шумовані ви вирішили
почути якщо ми вийдемо
з канавите все мібудинок на розбавляти
залишиться тієї стіни у нас так багато
крадішок квартиру все винесуть і я навчаюсь
від руки залишусь а не син А куди мені
виїжджають
так уб'ють А що робити А куди
хочеш удома
Містер куб яньської географічного
знаходиться ближче до російського кордону
нішдо харкова на польшатку вторгнині мер
Містер здався і російській скроні
укупували купленськ на 6 місяців
волонтери педозрію чедейки стик хто
відвідуєте їх А ти завищуються в нозі
ще Росія знову взаємно
ми їх називаю може Місяця я такі слова
натиснули в тих районах Які обмежити
Російська Федерація Україна макгрегором
окупантом такі люди присутні на
чистоту всі хто хотів
виїхав
він ще сидить
цілий слух від ітанади але
вона здорова людей
на тему рекламному щиті на в'їзді до
місця написано
Україна
інформацію
з 283
розслідування
стопори бувають укупеньку та їх
встановити
колаборації на діяльність вона довжина
стоїть Навіть поруч навіть тісно з військовими
злаченими я праворуч Так ми проходимо
домінку до людини А там уже публічно
виявляв це у соціальних міражах після
цієї інформації про російську, а потім
виявляється люди на наводи тракети та
агентом та ФСБ вона тут ми приїхала до
центру прийому біженців
дітям дають іграшки до кавана реєструйте
сім'я пряме місце
тут тільки вона не ви вирішити все працює
далі
[музика]